we know from these emails that their  first conclusion was essentially holy  [ __ ] this is bad describe  what many of the virologists in this  Inner Circle were saying about the virus  at that time amongst themselves the term  that they used was that the virus seemed  inconsistent with expectations from  evolutionary theory in other words  four days later Christian Anderson is  speaking to scientists who are putting  together a letter for the White House  and he uses the same phrase but inverted  he says a phrase I like to use with  these lab leak cranks is consistent with  Natural Evolution so essentially you are  doing a 180 change